could this be the car of the future
french car giant citroen hopes this
year's futuristic concept offering will
help boost sales after a two-year lull
the davine ds doesn't even carry the car
manufacturer's name but certainly makes
a statement
ds is trying to take on the established
idea of premium which has been set by
the german brands i mean it's trying to
do it in a particularly french way so
you're looking at sort of an extremely
overstyled perhaps slightly more
luxurious take on on what we've become
used to and i think any variety is good
for the industry
and it's certainly luxurious companies
like fashion jewellers swarovski and
embroidery house meson lessage have
helped with the design giving the ds
some vavavoom
its sister company peugeot is also in on
the act it hopes the exalt will take on
their german rivals
peugeot have got a big job to be done to
persuade people that they are really
rivals volkswagen and part of that is
showing exciting up market cars which
the exhaust certainly is whether we
actually see something like that on sale
very doubtful but it's a good intention
to show where peugeot is going in terms
of his brand
concept models from toyota lexus and
mini are also set to make their debuts
but one has to wonder if they'll ever
make it onto the road
they cost several million pounds to
develop so they're pretty far down the
line for most car manufacturers what
tends to happen is that you see them in
a slightly altered form and where the
designers have been reined in and where
some of the more extreme ideas can can
just
reach fruition and be seen on the road
tom gibson bloomberg